[Music]
so
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and i've been
using pixel 6 and pixel 6 pro
for about three weeks now
this is it this is the first year we're
expecting a real
google flagship right so previous pixels
have been pretty nice and they've had
great cameras and pretty cool software
features but overall pretty lackluster
hardware but this
is a step up we're expecting big things
a big new camera array a new design
language they made their own chip
there's a lot going for it so this is
their moon shot right this is their
chance to compete with the big dogs so
now that i've used them i will say these
are my favorite pixels ever and they are
the most google phones ever made for
sure but reality check
they're not perfect and there's
definitely some areas where they come up
a little bit short so i'm going to go
over those things but off the top i just
want to hit you with the prices first
okay so 5.99 for pixel 6 starting and
8.99 for the pixel 6 pro those are both
at 128 gigs
that's really competitive so there's a
lot of action already at that like 599
dollar price range but also the one they
keep calling a flagship which is the six
pro
this is the one that's here to take
shots at the iphones and samsung galaxy
s21 ultras of the world and it competes
but the six is the real deal so i've
grown to really like this camera bar
design for the pixels and the fact is it
is polarizing like it doesn't look quite
like any other phone theoretically you
know the huge new camera sensors need
all this thickness here but it could
have looked like any other phone like
the vivo x70 pro plus has the same 50
megapixel sensor but they went with a
camera rectangle but this visor it's a
look this is the uh the pixel phone look
now it's very easily recognizable and i
think that's on purpose and they can
keep it this way for at least a few
years and the bar design is functional i
will say my index finger does end up
resting nicely underneath the camera bar
when i'm holding it which is nice it
doesn't rock on a table either if you're
typing or using it out of your hand the
only weird part is it doesn't quite like
blend nicely into the aluminum sides of
this phone like i think it would have
been really cool if it was like a
seamless
blend like one piece like what samsung
did with the s21 ultra but there are a
lot of seams all over this camera module
but hey at the end of the day if you're
just going to toss the case on it like
this grip case from channel sponsor
dbrand it's basically just going to
cancel the bump anyway
but now you've got you know a flat even
phone you've got your icons logos but
it's still obviously a pixel underneath
that you still have the visor across the
back so i think it's a win unless you
think it's incredibly ugly in which case
try not to look at the back of the phone
too much but come on visors look cool
but the part you look at on the front of
the phone
is huge on both screens both of these
phones are huge and i think the the
question naturally is why didn't they
make a smaller one and i think google's
answer would be
well there are people who want to spend
less on a phone but most of those people
still want a big screen so they gave it
to him so pixel 6's screen is a pretty
massive 6.4 inches from corner to corner
90 hertz 1080p and flat and with pretty
small bezels overall and a hole punch in
the top middle for the selfie camera
it's a pretty good screen again for a
600 phone
but how about that flagship though so
with the 6 pro we're looking at 6.7
inches 1440p
and up to 120 hertz it is super super
sharp very responsive and has been an
absolute pleasure but since they're
saying it's the flagship
i can get a little more nitpicky here
these curved edges
they're kind of going out of style i
know that gets you even smaller bezels
and they are a little bit smaller but
the fact that it gets kind of a bit
darker in the very corners isn't doing
the screen any favors and there also is
a little bit of color shift off axis
that you really straight up just don't
see on the more expensive screens like
on the s21 ultra or the iphone 13 pro
also the fingerprint reader on the
display of both of these phones
is kind of slow so it appears to be an
optical sensor shining a light on your
finger instead of those new ultrasonic
ones samsung is using
and yeah it's gotten kind of annoying
after a while often it will take a full
like half second at least long enough
for me to get annoyed that i'm waiting
for it to read my finger i think they
could have used a better sensor here or
at least done this a little faster i am
comparing it to thousand dollar phones
though so again this is what i was
talking about earlier it's impressive
that it's hanging with the big dogs but
it is just undercutting it a little bit
now the top hole punch in the middle of
these displays houses the selfie camera
it's a pretty decent 8 megapixel wide
camera on the pixel 6 but it's closer to
an ultra wide selfie on the 6 pro which
i really like a lot and it's also bumped
up to 11 megapixels so it can also shoot
4k selfie video fits more people on the
frame big fan of the six pros selfie
camera and then also you know the little
things that you'd sort of expect a great
phone to do well but that you don't want
to have to think about too much like
clicky buttons
check both phones are fully water
resistant and the haptics are really
good on both phones as well so that's a
pixel thing but the biggest new piece
google's adding to these phones is
definitely on the inside and that would
be the new tensor chip
so designed by google for this phone
this is going to let them do in theory
things that they couldn't do with the
off-the-shelf qualcomm chip they'd used
before you know machine learning better
ai better computational photography all
kinds of things they want to focus on
with just this phone
they can do it and it's done that it's
really impressive now a lot of people
are wondering how tensor would benchmark
just
and i don't think that's the right way
to think about this new chip but just
out of curiosity i threw a geekbench at
it and we have the numbers it got 1035
on single core 2800 multi-core so that's
maybe 8 to 10
slower with the cpu on paper than the
snapdragon triple eight but also still
way way ahead of the snapdragon 765 g
they used on the pixel five last year
but then also i did uh some gpu
benchmarks from 3dmark and it was
looking at 10 to 12 faster than the
snapdragon triple a but that's clearly
not what tensor is about this this might
be the biggest this is what makes it a
googly phone this is the biggest
difference between
the benchmarks and what the phone is
actually capable of that i've ever seen
so first of all these phones have been
really quick and responsive no
performance problems for me i've mostly
been dailying the 6 pro which has got
the adaptive refresh rate up to 120
hertz and i've been loving that but it's
not about the performance as much as
it's about the features and this
continues a tradition of the pixel phone
being the smartest smartphone to come
out every year so you know besides the
stuff we've already seen like call
screening where google assistants can
filter incoming calls for you or now
playing which ambiently detects whatever
song is playing in the background in
your environment and just keeps a
running list so you can remember what
song was going on in the background in
the grocery store an hour ago and we've
seen live captioning of any and all
videos and phone calls and movies in
real time besides all of that
there is some new improved stuff thanks
to tensor and dedicated pieces of that
ship so first of all speech to text
unreal on this phone absolutely
incredible to the point where it
actually changes the way i use the phone
i try to use voice
more often on this phone because it's so
good so anywhere i'd normally be typing
i use that mic button anywhere i can and
no matter how fast you talk you can
basically rap at it you can talk 200
words per minute like eminem if you want
to and it'll just keep going quick it
also adds punctuation really accurately
so you don't really even have to think
about that you're just automatically
grammatically accurate all the time
this is going to make sitting in
lectures and people in class taking
notes way less stressed and basically
anywhere else transcription is useful
and even on top of all that it's smart
so if you say a name it will pull from
the names in your contacts try to make
sure it spells it right if there's
multiple different spellings of names
for something and you correct it once it
will remember that corrected spelling of
a name things like that if you say
delete this or send
it doesn't type those words it knows
what you're trying to do and will
actually delete the words or send the
message now there's also a new feature
in google photos for pixel six that lets
you go back to any picture in your
library and erase the things that you
don't want now this isn't blowing your
mind if you've seen content aware phil
on photoshop before but i'm mostly
really impressed with how easy and
simple it makes the process so you go
into any image go to tools and it's
called magic eraser and it automatically
selects what it thinks you want to
remove usually a background photo bomber
of some sort and then you can just do it
and if there's other stuff you want to
remove you can draw a sloppy outline
around it it will auto detect the edges
usually really well with any sort of
contrast finds the object you're talking
about and just removes it just like that
so it kind of reads like magic and
people on twitter loved it but just like
photoshop's content aware feel
it has certain things it works really
well on and other things not so much so
it works best with simple repeating
backgrounds you know maybe gradients or
textures and with a lot of contrast
but if you try to get rid of like a
large object that's in front of several
different backgrounds well that's just
gonna look bad like that's difficult for
ai but i was very impressed with some of
the things that pulled off just messing
around with it it's probably a gimmick
feature still for most people but this
is yet another demo of the powerful ai
and tensor that can be pretty great
sometimes now something i thought would
be better with tensor
is battery life
and you know maybe i was getting my
hopes up too high because
what i saw apple do with their silicon
has been amazing like their chips are
basically the pinnacle
of efficiency not to compare too much
but when i see iphone 13 pro max getting
eight plus hours of screen on time easy
with a 4300 milliamp hour battery
that's pretty amazing so now i see pixel
6 come out
40 600 milliamp hour battery in the
pixel 6 and 5 000 milliamp hours in the
6 pro
and they design their own chips so i was
thinking this would be amazing
it's not so i was consistently getting
three and a half to four and a half
hours of screen on time on the pixel 6
pro and slightly less on the six
which is just
average at best it's not that great like
that's dead by the end of a long day
pretty often now on a 600 phone that's
not too crazy you can probably forgive
that but on a flagship
that's a weakness and then also on top
of that you got to remember there is no
charging brick in the box like we saw
and it supports up to 30 watts of wired
charging which is not super fast but
it's it's okay and the wireless charging
that's supported is even a little bit
slower than that so the battery
situation for me has been overall kind
of a bummer on the flagship i can get
around it by just charging all the time
like in my car at my desk at work
but you never really want to have to do
that you kind of just want to be able to
use your phone normally and not think
about it but hey using this phone when
it's not running low on battery has been
awesome thanks to android 12. i want to
use it all the time totally made over
aesthetic material you and all kinds of
visual overhaul happening here so i made
an entire video about all the new
features here which i'll link below that
like button but yeah i really like most
of it at first it definitely feels like
a little spread out like there's a lot
of extra blank and like white space in
the ui there's these huge ui elements
and really big buttons and especially on
a huge phone with a huge screen it feels
kind of cartoonish at first but it all
comes together it's sort of this big
flowing bouncy ui with matching colors
and lots of nice scrolling physics and
haptics it all ties together but yeah
it's just nice that no matter what
wallpaper i choose for example the quick
settings and the settings app and all
the menu backgrounds and widgets all
find an accent color in the wallpaper
and match it right away it's just it's
so sweet it's nice it's nice my only
little gripe with android 12
is two things actually one that the
brightness slider is two swipes away
it's all the way at the top and you got
to drag it down i i just think that
could be way more reachable and way more
accessible
and the other thing is i don't like the
new internet toggle
i usually just want to turn wi-fi on or
off but now that takes an extra tap
and i feel like they could just add a
wi-fi toggle in the quick settings but
just a general internet one exists but
you know what when you think about pixel
what do you think of you think of the
software and the camera i think the
software is pretty great so let's talk
about the most distinctive part of this
phone the camera so pixels have had the
same camera more or less since the pixel
2 right this small 12 megapixel sensor
on the pixel 2 was pretty revolutionary
for its time
and so they kept the same one in pixel
3. and then kept the same one in pixel
four
and then kept the same one in pixel five
and it was fine because others were
catching up around them with better
hardware but google had figured out a
really great way to compensate for the
small sensor with incredible software
amazing computational photography great
hdr and multi-frame bracketing and all
this stuff that made their images their
night sight all of those photos look
incredible it was almost like they just
proved with these cameras that the
software is more important than the
hardware itself but now here we are in
2021 everyone's catching up and so now
pixel 6 has launched with a brand new
camera system featuring a much better
hardware suite a huge 50 megapixel main
sensor but you can't actually take 50
megapixel photos there's no high res
mode or anything for it it's always
binning and everything is down to 12 and
a half megapixels
and then there's a new 12 megapixel
ultra wide and the pro phone also gets a
4x telephoto camera as well so okay been
shooting with it
i think
google's still running all of their
camera algorithms at 11 like when they
don't need to anymore so this has much
better hardware and they had been
compensating like i said for a smaller
weaker sensor to bring it up and bring
out all the magic
and now
running that same type of look starts to
make photos look a bit over processed a
little over hdr-y pretty frequently so
there are a bunch of interesting things
about this camera but like i said 50
megapixels doing 4-1 binning with no
option to keep all 50 means you're only
really getting a small amount of
improved sharpness over the previous but
photos are sharp white balance is pretty
good but still bias is a little bit too
cool sometimes but you can see in
regular lighting the pixel does an
enormous amount of hdr and it almost
looks like someone turned up the clarity
slider in photoshop just a little bit
too high so shadows never quite get all
the way to black and it's very rare that
highlights like the sky are ever blown
out but then yeah that also gives you a
bit of an exaggerated like
over-processed look when the photo
should just have regular lighting now
the thing is this sensor is amazing so
it's taking in a ton of light and a lot
of information so actually the more
difficult high dynamic range shooting
situations are handled great like
shooting directly into the sun or
shooting at night with bright lights
these more difficult shots are actually
very impressive looking now because the
processing is keeping so much
information in the final shot
but even so these darker scenes tend to
overexpose when you don't adjust the
slider in the viewfinder so it's really
impressive believe me having all this
sharpness and almost no noise in a
nighttime shot
that's technically
incredible but it shouldn't look this
bright so here's a comparison shot with
the iphone 13 pro on full auto just to
give you an idea of the difference
between night modes it's almost turning
night into day on the pixel but here's a
pretty perfect example to visualize all
this processing on the left is a raw
shot from the pixels camera that we
colored with just a quick boost to the
vibrance and on the right side is a
google process jpeg
and that sensor you can see is getting a
ton of information and detail
and the processing
is to make it look like what it thinks
we want on a phone screen again bringing
up the shadows bringing down the
highlights sharpening everything
but i think the ideal might be somewhere
in between these now the ultrawide is
pretty good it's not amazing but it has
a lot of the same traits as last year
and i'm glad they're still in ultra wide
there's no macro mode with it though and
then the telephoto on the pro was
surprisingly good when you're moving
around handheld although you still get
much better sharpness out of like an s21
ultra google super resume is pretty good
at sharpening up and improving shots
that would normally be soft but they can
still tend to look a little bit like a
watercolor painting at the extremes but
overall you know as someone who's loved
the pixel's rich contrast look and
really honestly preferred it for years
over pretty much anything else
i think this is an almost great camera
that can take some tweaks and and maybe
some software updates at least i'm
hoping to get better because i i've
taken some incredible sharp photos with
this camera and i've also taken some
weird looking ones so basically i guess
the question is would you rather have a
camera that's a 10 out of 10
sometimes but also a 7 out of 10 some
other times
or just a camera that just gives you 9
out of 10 9 9 nine every single time
because that's the iphone that nine out
of ten that consistent shot the iphone
13 pro's camera system is more
consistent
but the pixels camera aces some shots
sometimes but then also gives me
a really weird over hdr looking shot
that i wouldn't even want to share so
bounces back and forth i will say the
video from the pixel did really level up
kind of the same style as the photos it
has great dynamic range great
stabilization and that big sensor is
giving you real background blur and
impressively staying in focus most of
the time and in some of these harder
scenes you can definitely see the
processing working like here when it's
trying to bring up the shadows it's
pretty noisy but still overall color and
exposure and white balance and the
details are all great with the pixel 6's
video and i'm really happy to see that
and then another thing i noticed the
pixel really cranks iso all the way up
in the viewfinder so you can see a lot
of noise before you snap a photo and
start the processing like it's very easy
to see this here in a screen recording
but that's what it's doing you can see
in a selfie viewfinder especially it'll
look super jacked up and really noisy
just to keep a high frame rate and
shutter speed when you're taking the
selfie and then you take it and you see
it process and then everything sharpens
up and it looks miles better
and while that seemed kind of weird to
me at first i actually think this is a
good move so tensor has a horsepower to
just run the stuff at high iso and the
preview might not look great but at
least it's not choppy and laggy and then
it basically under promises and over
delivers people will see the viewfinder
and think this will be a bad photo and
then they'll be shocked at how good the
final photo is when you're taking photos
with faces in them the ultrawide camera
is always running at a higher shutter
speed so if you get someone moving too
quick and the primary camera has a
blurry face it can merge in the faster
sharper face from the ultrawide camera
into your shot automatically i mean
that's
you kind of just never have blurry faces
in your photos overall just as someone
who's used now both of these phones for
a couple weeks
iphone's camera system
is better than the pixels
it just is right now it doesn't it's
more consistent it doesn't struggle with
over processing it shoots to more
formats it's a better overall camera
system but
this the hardware is so good in the
pixels and you can see that promise in
those 10 out of 10 shots
that
the pixel fan in me is like hoping maybe
in one or two software updates
it'll be a 10 out of 10 more often but
until then because we don't know if
that's ever gonna happen
yeah you saw the sample shots that's
that's what it does that's how it looks
so
yeah i want to come back to the price at
the end here like i said 5.99 for pixel
6
8.99 for pixel 6 pro it's a 300 delta
and for that difference you're getting
120 hertz over 90 1440p over 1080 a
curved screen over a flat one
some glossy sides over the matte sides i
like the matte sides better then you get
an extra telephoto camera on the back
and you get a wider selfie camera on the
front a little more ram a little bit
bigger screen
that's kind of it so basically my
conclusion is
pixel 6
really good phone really really great
deal because for 600 bucks this is one
of the best ones you can get
and then the difference in money to get
to six pro
it makes it a better phone than the
pixel six sure a lot of good stuff here
but this stuff doesn't vault it over the
top of all the other flagships
it just you know i would get this phone
if you've really got to have the
telephoto or the ultra wide selfie
camera or the bigger faster screen
that's kind of the main bullets but i
think pixel 6 is almost incredible and
the truth is
this is the most important google phone
yet this this pivot to
you know from enthusiast phones and
really cool cameras and software
features to still being the smartest
smartphone in the world but also now
having much better hardware this new
design and making their own chip and
competing
like really competing
i'm into it i'm super into it so that's
fun to see
that's pixel six and six pro
it's techtober so there's still a lot
more to talk about so stay tuned for
that stuff subscribe if you haven't
already thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]